It might shock you to hear this, but Donald
Trump is back to doing rallies. He was shot
out of a cannon yesterday, rampant speculation
that Donald Trump is still under the influence
of steroids because he did seem manic.
And I have to tell you, I have never
seen Donald Trump speak this quickly or act as
manically or maniacally choose which one you like
as he did last night. But we will get to that
because first I have to set the context for you.
Donald Trump, who reportedly only first tested
negative for Corona virus since having it
on the flight to Sanford, Florida, did a
mass rally yesterday in the state of Florida,
which, as you can see, if you're watching
along with me, very few masks even on the
stage behind Donald Trump, essentially no masks
among the crowd, not on the stage right behind
him. They do not care much the same way that
Trump's rallies aren't politics. Are more like
sporting events. Trump's crowds are not connected
to the reality of a global pandemic. It is not
just some of their ideas that are in the 1950s.
Their day to day is nine months stale from when
we didn't have a pandemic. Usually at least the
people on the screen behind on the stage who are
on screen behind Trump are told you have to wear
masks here. More than half of the people even
onstage visible behind Trump didn't have masks on.
And then before we get into some of the specifics,
just a little bit about the atmospherics.
Aside from the barely any masks situation
and no social distancing whatsoever, Florida
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis was at the rally
without a mask. High firing rally goers touching
everybody's hands. We have video of it that we've
been showing our audience as if once again,
there has been no global pandemic raging for
the last eight months. Now you really have to
see it to believe it. So that's the context
in which this rally is happening. Marsalis,
Republican governor, high five ing people,
no social distancing. Very few masks. A recently
coded positive president delivering a speech. Now
on to the speech. Donald Trump appeared
completely manic. Now, the speculation,
of course, is that it's still the dexamethasone
or simply that Trump was given a steroid so that
he would have more energy for the rally. He did
seem tired towards the end, struggling more to
project his voice and breathe. But he was out of
control. Trump again alluding to the consequences
of crimes that still have not yet been enumerated
by Obama, Biden and Hillary. Bizarre, dystopian,
authoritarian moment. Take a look.
Because we are doing more
for this country than any administration has ever
done, despite the witch hunts and the phony stuff
that we caught them on. Now we caught him cold
and we'll see what happens with that. Just watch.
Stay tuned. So, of course, this is completely
authoritarian strongmen. Trump last week said
that Joe Biden should be indicted. And Trump still
has not been able to tell us what laws were broken
by Barack Obama, by Joe Biden, by Hillary Clinton.
The crowd doesn't care. The crowd loves it. Trump
then referred to his campaign as a campaign
and another one of these verbal glitches. And
you'll see this one take shape very quickly.
We achieved all of this despite the fact
that we caught them cold. They were
spying on our campaign. It's our
campaign. It's our campaign, not my campaign.
Trump did that thing there where his brain
realizes that what's coming out of his mouth
doesn't make any sense. So he sort of just
stops short and restarts a different sentence.
We've seen it happen at this time. At this point,
dozens and dozens of times. Trump then again
with this entire we're going to take care of
them after the election. Horribly authoritarian.
And it actually leads to chants of lock them up
again, sort of a staple of the Trump rally
calling for the jailing without due process of
Trump's political adversaries. Take a look.
But we'll take care of it all after
the election. We got him cold.
We got him. Bad people, crooked Hillary.
And by the way, Obama and Biden knew
everything that was happening. OK. Just
in case you had any question. We'll take
care of it after the election. Joe Biden,
the Democrat socialist, but that gives you another
reason to go out and vote. We got to get in
as we know.
They'll just sweep it under the rug.
You also hear in addition to lock them up.
Trump again referring to Biden as a socialist.
We had a good phone call about
this last week from someone saying
during live calls, a young lady called
in and said, listen, my family believes
Joe Biden is a socialist. When I try to
talk to him, tell him about the election.
They say that Joe Biden is a socialist. He's got
her family's Cuban. We're going to be like Cuba.
Exhibit A. Castro again. And I don't know what to
say when they say that whenever someone says Biden
is socialist. The first question must be which
socialist policies are is Biden advocating for?
Usually that will short circuit like 95
percent, you know, 19 out of 20 of those
diatribes. And they'll move on to something
else. Because the answer is, obviously, Biden
is not advocating for any socialist policies.
Much to the chagrin of actual socialists who want
a further left Democratic presidential candidate.
But doesn't matter. Facts don't matter. All that
matters is feelings at Trump's rally. Trump then
taking his anger out on the media. Here he is
saying that the media are the sickest of them all.
These people are the sickest of all.
You know, turning an entire crowd against
reporters and camera people in the back of
the room is is very strong man dictator ish.
It really is. And I'm sure you all know that.
And then this moment totally wild. Trump
saying he feels so good. And again,
this could be the steroids talking dexamethasone
and other steroids can make you euphoric.
Trump saying he feels so damn good that
Cauvin Trump wants to go into the audience
and kiss the men and the attractive women.
Take a look at this.
If you want to get out there, get
out. One thing was me, the nice part.
I went through it. Now they say I'm
immune. I can feel I feel so powerful.
I'll walk into that. I'll walk
in there and kiss everyone and
I'll kiss the guys in the beautiful women.
And every mile just give you a big factors.
No, but there is something nice. I don't
have to be locked up in my basement and I
wouldn't allow that to happen anyway.
So that's Trump's manic upper voice,
which we've come to recognize. It's at a twelve
since he's been on whatever medications he's
been on for Corona virus. Trump continuing
to mock Joe Biden, by the way, for having
safe events. Trump ridiculing Biden while he
has he being Trump has super spreader events.
You know, these are the real polls. So when did
you hear about this meeting? Like a day ago.
These are the real polls, right?
The other guy gets out there, ATI's. They
worked and worked and worked. And 30 people show
up. They put him in those crazy circles. Right.
They only have the circles because that's the
only way they could fill up the room. It's true.
Trump himself appears to have caught Corona virus
at an event he organized at the White House for
Amy CONI Barrett. And he's laughing at Joe Biden.
He laughed at him during the debate for wearing
masks. He's now laughing at Joe Biden for having
small, socially distant campaign events. And the
crowd just loves it. The crowd is cheering the guy
who caught Coronavirus at one of his own events
for saying the other guy's events
aren't full of people during a pandemic.
It's backwards. Everything that's happening is
completely backwards. And there was no I'm not
going to play the clip for you for this next clip.
But there was another hilariously ignorant moment
during the rally where if you watched behind
Trump, there were people with blacks for Trump
shirts. There were people with Latinos for
Trump shirts. There were some Puerto Rico
shirts, Puerto Ricans for Trump. And Trump said
at one point, Puerto Rico better vote for me.
Now, of course, Puerto Rico doesn't vote
in the presidential election because it's
not a state. I would love for Puerto Rico to be
a state. Many on the left would love for Puerto
Rico to be a state. Trump still confused about
Puerto Rico even at this late stage in the game.
These rallies are going to continue this week.
I'll be covering both Trump and Biden events
this week. Also, an update, debate number two
was scheduled for Thursday when the Commission
on Presidential Debates said we'll do it virtual
because Trump has covered Trump said no. Then the
debate has been canceled altogether. The latest is
that Joe Biden will be doing a 90 minute town hall
and that Trump is pursuing a competing town
hall. We don't know if it will be back to
back on different networks at the same time on
different networks. I don't know. But I'm here.
We are here through Election Day, so I will be
covering whatever it is that ultimately happens.